[Music]
if you watch the 1933 film king kong
closely you might notice
a slight rippling effect across the
puppet's fur
you'll notice the same effect if you
watch wes anderson's stop motion films
fantastic mr fox and isle of dogs
the rippling is a side effect of using
real animal fur
something anderson wanted because he
liked the aesthetic of the 1933 king
kong film
anderson's crew pushed back against the
idea because
when animators hands adjust the puppets
for each frame
they leave impressions in the fur
creating a rippling
almost windswept effect something that
can be avoided
by using synthetic fur but when it came
to having a visible artifact of the
crew's hands
in the film itself this didn't bother
anderson
film critic madzilla seitz recounts
talking to wes anderson about the
decision to use animal fur
here he just wanted animal fur
you know he couldn't even explain why
really he just wanted it
and but it was partly that uh the idea
of a personal touch i said well you can
sort of see the fingerprints on the
creation he said well in this case
literally
this video is brought to you by movie go
to movie.com thomasflight for your
extended 30 day free trial
all the criterion collection commentary
tracks even since the days of the
laserdiscs i think begin with the
standard setup so we'll do
we should probably do that this is the
director's commentary for the darjeeling
limited featuring wes anderson roman
coppola and jason schwartzman
right in the middle of the commentary
there's a funny little moment where the
recording
is interrupted by a phone call
hang on one second hello
oh you know can i call call him back
because we're just recording something
right now
okay thank you bye
sorry this moment somehow strikes me as
one of the most
wes anderson sorts of things the analog
sound of the telephone and the response
itself feels like
something out of a wes anderson film but
it's also
the desire to leave that moment in the
director's commentary instead of just
cutting it out
that feels very characteristically wes
anderson
but what makes something
characteristically wes anderson
let me tell you about my boat what is
that wes anderson style we all know it
when we
see it and it's been broken down into
countless pieces and examined by
countless video essayists according to
those essays it's
symmetry it's long lateral tracking
shots it's
immaculately arranged flat lace slow
motion
whip pans or countless other visual
quirks
but what is at the core of those
individual stylistic decisions
why does anderson choose those things
and why do all those things seem to form
a very specific unified whole
and what function if any do they serve
in telling the kinds of stories
wes wants to tell
to work some of these things out let's
focus on one aspect of wes's visual
style
one that i think encompasses many other
elements of his style
this element critic david bordwell has
identified and called
planometric composition planometric
composition
is the orientation of elements of a
scene
especially the background as flat planes
relative
to the camera planometric composition
wasn't invented by wes anderson it's
used by a lot of other filmmakers
but wes adheres to it and uses it
probably more
than anyone else in film in this scene
from the darjeeling limited
pay attention to what all these shots
have in common compositionally
[Music]
oh
you don't love me they all keep the
background of the shot
as a relatively flat plane these kinds
of shots existed in anderson's
filmography from the very beginning but
as his career has progressed he's used
planometric composition
with greater precision and for a larger
portion of his films
in addition to the background being a
flat plane characters usually
occupy and move through flat planes
within the scene that run
parallel to the background in the grand
budapest we can see wes
usually orients his characters along
these planes
either facing directly towards or away
from the camera
or perpendicular to the camera in the
profile view
to maintain this planimetric composition
as he moves the camera around
and through scenes and as he edits
between different shots within a scene
wes employs something bordwell calls
compass point editing
in compass point editing and camera work
the camera only really faces
in four directions whenever the camera
pans it pans in 90 degree increments
in order to keep the walls of the
environment flat
when he cuts he usually cuts in 90 or
180 degrees
if you think about it this isn't really
a technique so much as
a necessity to maintain planometric
composition
in a standard environment with four
walls wes maintains this rule when he
moves the camera on a dolly the camera
moves directly forward
backward or sideways along these
specific axes
these two rules define many aspects of
anderson's
styling especially in his more recent
films within them he has some
flexibility he allows the camera to tilt
up and down as long as it remains
perpendicular to the background
to understand the why behind wes
anderson's use of this style of
composition
and its effect it helps us to ask why
most filmmakers
avoid this type of composition it's
because
flat compositions usually look and feel
constructed a flat composition
feels self-conscious
naturalism is the prevailing approach to
film form
at least in most films americans watch
even for outrageous unbelievable stories
the approach to filmmaking in most films
is one that attempts to
hide the filmmaking itself from the
audience
take for example the rotating hallway
scene in
inception if you compare this scene to
this chase down a hallway from the grand
budapest hotel
which is more realistic of the two the
scene from inception
is the one presenting a reality that is
technically impossible
it's a fantasy but everything about how
christopher nolan chooses to shoot this
scene
is meant to disguise its unreality and
present it
as a reality the situation in anderson's
scene
is realistic and totally possible but
everything about how he
presents that situation makes it feel
like a fantasy one has unrealistic
content
and realistic form and the other has
realistic content
and fanciful form instead of attempting
to hide itself
it draws attention to itself this
composition from bong joon-ho's parasite
is no less precise and
intentional than this one from grand
budapest
we know because we can see how precisely
bong joon-ho planned things out in his
storyboards but it's the flatness
and center framing of this shot from
grand budapest
that draws our attention to its
precision
[Music]
this is the wes anderson collection a
book of essays and interviews by critic
matt solar sites who has done extensive
work
cataloging and championing wes's films
and style
here wes recounts a story to matt about
an argument he had with his agent
over the curtains in rushmore in
rushmore we had these curtains with the
months projected on them and my agent
who i love was like
yeah you don't need that that's just a
show-off thing it doesn't help it takes
you out of the story and the reality of
the movie
and i can tell there's a curtain on a
movie set there because it looks like a
real thing
it's supposed to look like a real thing
i know but i can tell there's a curtain
where you're shooting it
i know yeah but there's not supposed to
be it's supposed to be people
real people well i know that yes but i
do want the curtain there
for me often what might take somebody
else out of it is what i think is just
the most beautiful
thing the curtains in rushmore along
with planometric compositions
are examples of the fingerprints of the
filmmaker being visible
in the work itself
the fingerprints of the director and his
crew have been all over west's movies
long before they showed up
literally and fantastic mr fox i think
this is the defining aspect of
many of the elements that make up what
we recognize as wes anderson's style
to an extent wes is just following his
personal taste but it's the way that
taste
works together with his disregard for
naturalism
that defines his style as a whole wes
doesn't care if you know there's a
director making the movie
that there's somebody pulling back the
curtain and telling you a story
in fact he's happy to highlight that
this reveals itself
sometimes in incredibly subtle ways like
the slight shaky
imperfections in many of the pans and
dolly shots in some of his films it's
not that these shots
couldn't be smooth and precise the film
equipment and crew needed to do these
moves almost flawlessly
exist and are within anderson's budget
but anderson prefers these shots to have
these subtle human imperfections
anderson's use of
varying aspect ratios in the grand
budapest hotel also reflects this idea
it's a narrative device that works it
delineates clearly between the time
periods in the story but it's also a
device that
explicitly draws your attention to the
moviness
of the movie it's impossible to see the
aspect ratio switch and not be subtly
reminded
you're watching a movie made by somebody
not enough smoke and the snow was too
loud we'll go again right away
i've blown up buildings hunted sharks
crashed airplanes and
anyway american express commercial here
we go can i get my snack what are you
doing
critic david bordwell identifies wes
anderson the director
as a brand and while wes himself
certainly
has a brand and an image my best friend
sounds fake there are stories of how he
curates his public persona
and personal style and there are moments
like the telephone call in the
darjeeling limited commentary
but i think it goes deeper than this i
think wes anderson
as a director becomes a character in his
films
his films are often shrouded in layers
of artificial authorial framing
that seem to point back to a creator the
grand budapest is a story being told by
zero to the author well it begins as it
must with our
mutual friend's predecessor but wes
doesn't start the film there
instead we see the author telling the
story of how he came across
the story to the audience him who has
often told the tales of others
many tales will be told but wes also
doesn't start the film
here it's not zero or even the author
who
acts as the authorial framing of the
film he starts the film on a young girl
who's read the book
this outward expansion almost draws our
attention to the next
unnamed outer layer of the question
who's telling the story
we're looking at now the royal tenon
bombs is presented as a book
rushmore with curtains like a play the
life aquatic with steve zisu is a sort
of film within a film
the darjeeling limited has a character
that seems to be writing the story where
inside of moonrise kingdom has a
narrator that speaks
to the camera these films relieve
themselves of naturalism
presenting themselves as stories and
every story
has a storyteller in the life aquatic we
find the story of a filmmaker who
endlessly tries to control and craft the
world around him we see stories of
characters that are meticulous and
quirky in their approach to life
we see family-like teams that travel and
work together on
projects would you like to join my crew
i want you on team zuzu an approach wes
has used often
in making his own films for example
while making the darjeeling limited
not only was the film written by three
guys as they traveled around
india by train it was also shot on a
train while the crew
traveled around the country and i think
it's this aspect of director as
character that makes
wes's films so appealing to anyone
interested
in filmmaking his films are meticulously
constructed but
so are the films of many other
filmmakers so it's not that
meticulousness of his direction
so much as it's the visibility of his
meticulousness that draws filmmakers
and those who love filmmaking to his
work
and if inserting yourself as a character
into your films feels very
self-interested to you i suppose you
could read it that way
but i think something more interesting
is going on interviews with wes and the
extensive references
in his movies to varied and sometimes
obscure cinema
reveal his genuine love for filmmaking
and storytelling
i think wes having a love not just of
stories themselves but the act of
storytelling just isn't
shy about pulling back the curtain just
a little in a certain way
and showcasing the act of storytelling
alongside
the stories themselves
some people flat out reject the idea of
being reminded they're being told a
story
it takes them out of things completely
this may explain at least why some
people have a
viscerally negative reaction to wes
anderson's films it's not that i don't
like it i am physically repulsed
others might have concerned that a sort
of meta-awareness of a story's own
narrative construct
will rob the story of dramatic impact
and true sentimentality
and it's true that meta-narrative
awareness in an ironic sense has been
used
to casually dismantle sentiment and
notions of the value of narratives as a
whole
but i don't think it has to be and i
think we often overestimate how much it
detracts
from a story's ability to convey emotion
[Music]
hey buddy buddy david lowry
the director of ghost story and the
upcoming film the green knight
has a short film that i really like
called pioneer this 15-minute short film
is just a father
telling an epic bedtime story to his son
one day i was out planting food for us
to eat
and i heard the sound of thunder at no
point during this short film
can you forget that the father is just
telling a story
and yet it can be exciting and
emotionally engaging
all the same it reflects what is likely
our earliest experience
with narrative one where we can see the
storyteller
i think this might be part of why wes's
films even though they deal with rather
harsh realities
and for the most part aren't for
children have a sense of childish
playfulness to them
because there's a sense of childlike
innocence in this mode of storytelling
in acknowledging that you're being told
a story we all suspend disbelief to some
degree when we consume a story
we aren't really tricked into thinking
it's a real thing that
is happening good compelling stories
feel real to us
even when we know they're just stories
and i think
one of the things that wes anderson's
work can show us is that you can place
genuine emotion and sentiment within a
very constructed
and artificial world and it can still be
effective
we don't have any trouble feeling
emotion in
other kinds of stories that have layers
of ridiculous
and fanciful elements it's just that
wes's artificial world
takes on a different aesthetic not that
of fantasy or science fiction but of
authorial presence there's a moment in
almost every one of wes's films that i
love i still wish i could breathe
underwater
me too
it's for these most intimate emotionally
resonant moments that wes
pulls back from his style into something
more conventional
where he hides his filmmaking in a more
naturalistic approach temporarily
and just allows the story performance
and emotion to shine through when this
artificiality falls away to reveal
a very raw emotion underneath it always
kind of takes me by surprise
it's a unique effect and it wouldn't
really be possible if wes
weren't building up so many layers of
stylized artificiality to begin with
in the wes anderson collection for the
grand budapest hotel
metzler seitz ends his interview with
wes
on a unique question
and what's his filmic universe when the
creator intervenes
i wonder if he leaves his fingerprints
on his creations
i said earlier that naturalism is the
prevailing approach to the filmmaking of
most american mainstream cinema but wes
anderson is far from the first filmmaker
to break this convention and make more
stylized films
you can find a lot more of this kind of
thing in the world of
art house independent and foreign films
and if you want to explore that world
i recommend you check out movie hooby is
an online streaming platform with a
curated library that they add to every
day this year i've been working on a
feature script and one of my key
inspirations has been the filmmaker
joanna hogg
and right now on mubi they have two of
her films if you're interested in
watching those movies or just checking
out what else
mubi has to offer you can do that for
free right now if you sign up for an
extended free trial by going to mubi.com
thomasflight click the link in the
description or go to mubi.com
thomasflight for your extended 30-day
free trial
thank you so much for watching i
appreciate all of your views and support
if you want to support my channel
directly you can go to patreon.com
thomasflight
that's not a safe house dude